PRESENTER: In 1869, players
in the first football game
used a round ball
like in soccer.
It was tough to carry
and awkward to throw,
so they changed it to look
more like a watermelon.
The current shape
enables a better grip
in passing on an arc
that's unique to football.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
A lot of people handle
a football before it
ever gets to the field.
They start with cowhide.
Footballs are traditionally
made of this leather
because it wears well over time.
With a die, a worker cuts
out the four sections
that make up the ball's skin.
A stamping machine then brands
the skin with the company logo.
They may put other markings
elsewhere on the ball
depending on the design of
the model they're making.
Each of the sections goes into
a machine that trims the pieces'
combined weight down to spec.
To strengthen the
skin, a seamstress
sews cotton and vinyl linings
onto all four sections,
then she places them in
a die that positions them
for another set of markings.
These four white lines
will form two stripes when
the sections come together.
This is purely aesthetic
and varies according
to the football model.
Now it's time to sew the
top sections together
and then the bottom
ones to each other.
Exactly how many
stitches this takes
is this company's
closely guarded secret.
This press makes a hole
in one of the top sections
for the air valve.
They make eight holes in
the top sections for laces
that'll hold the skin tightly
around an inflated bag called
a bladder.
To join the ball's top
and bottom sections,
the seamstress first
cups them and then
joins the edges together.
She sews the leather
inside out to make
the stitches less visible.
Later, workers will
turn the skin right
side out by reaching through the
opening between the lace holes.
This is also where they'll
insert the bladder.
It's important to
flatten the four seams.
To do this, a worker
places each one on a wheel
as a roller passes over the top.
This keeps the ball from
being bumpy when they stretch
the skin over the bladder.
A 15-second steam
softens the leather
and makes it easier
to manipulate.
A concave press flattens
the seams at the tips.
This will also keep the ball
smooth when they inflate it.
Time to turn the
skin right side out.
A worker places it
on a metal bar, then,
reaching through the opening
between the lace holes,
he grabs the other side of
the skin and pulls it through.
Then he runs the bar along the
inside to reshape the skin.
The bladder is made
of polyurethane,
a type of plastic,
with a vinyl patch
reinforcing the lacing area.
After squeezing the
bladder inside the skin,
a worker steps off the
end of the air valve
to keep it out of the way.
Then she inflates
the bladder a bit
to make it rigid
enough for lacing.
After setting the
ball with clamps,
she uses an awl to thread
the lace through the holes.
Just one vinyl lace
measuring four feet,
it worms through both sides
and then down the center
and through all the
holes once again.
The lacing's spaced
about a half-inch apart--
wide enough to comfortably
grip for that magic
pass you've got in mind.
Next, workers temporarily
over-inflate the balls.
Steel molds surround
them to ensure they'll
assume the correct shape.
After 90 seconds, the
extra air seeps out.
Finally, the factory
inspects the balls to ensure
they're up to standard.
Fully inflated, a ball must
weigh no more than 15 ounces.
It should measure 21 and 1/2
inches through the middle
and 28 inches around both ends.
After a five-day
manufacturing process,
these balls are
ready for the field.